what's going on guys this is Rob and you
read that right Dr Doom's X-Men dominate
The X-Men I know it sounds crazy it's
amazing check this out so this opens up
in the very early days of Jonathan
Hickman's house and powers of X which is
to say when you had Charles Xavier and
Magneto and MOA m tager a character that
Marvel fumbled worse than a high school
guy trying to ask out a college girl
right when they're all together and you
initially have Xavier who broadcast to
the world right at the beginning of all
this for those you guys who didn't
follow House of powers of X when CCO was
originally formed as a safe haven for
the mutant population Xavier made this
broadcast to the world and was like
allow all your mutants to leave or
there's going to be consequences right
it was really really cool but one of the
things that happened that we didn't know
about is that in the midst of this right
Xavier says humans of planet Earth I am
the mutant Charles Xavier and I bring
you a message of Hope and then this
voice comes out of nowhere and says I've
been waiting for you to announce
yourself right you're not powerful
enough to speak to the world at once so
I'm positing that you're using cerebra
and frankly you're not that confident so
I'm going to make another supposition
that you're standing beside our old
friend Eric and when you have Moira who
asks like is something wrong and this
guy responds and says I am not nothing I
am doom and it's really cool because
there's this kind of like back and forth
conversation now I think it also needs
to be said Dr Doom has his own version
of cerebra how far reaching this is I
don't know traditionally in Marvel com I
cerebra was used by Xavier and even
cerebra right with an a it was used by
Xavier to either scan the world of the
mutant population influence all the
minds of all the mutants across the
world but it had like vast applications
it even became sentient once in one of
the weirdest story lines that Marvel
ever had but I don't know what Dr Doom's
version of cerebro can do but it does
allow him to seemingly override the
telepathic abilities of Charles Xavier
which does make sense right considering
how intelligent Dr Doom is as well as
how powerful he is it was really only a
matter of time before he overrode the
telepathic abilities of Xavier and so
the thing here is that like literally
Xavier's like I'm about to address the
entire world Doom right not just you so
as impresses I am that you can talk back
and then there's a little bit of banter
that kind of goes back and forth and
what Doom really just kind of says here
is this whole grand scheme you have of
like the mutant population residing
anera and all that kind of stuff it's
born BN from a desire to achieve greater
good but the reality here is it's going
to end in Fire and death there's no way
this comes out well for the mutant
population for any number of reasons but
your tenuous alliances with the various
Nations that exist out there will be
just that tenuous and when the time
comes Humanity will make a move they
will strike against a mutant population
and that'll be it now the cool thing
here is that much like other nations
like the United States and Russia and so
on and so forth that laveria does have
mutants within its own Nation but Dr
Doom while he doesn't necessarily
control them with an Iron Fist and in
fact you'll see what kind of
manipulations he does in order to sort
of keep them under control that he's
just like they're not going to leave one
because they don't want to and two even
if they did I wouldn't let them right
that's not going to happen and so you
basically FastTrack to what's going on
in Marvel Comics right now with like the
whole fall of exent humanity making its
move against a mutant population right
hosts of mutants just being killed off
all over the place and we get this kind
of a adjustment here right like week one
month one year one and so seemingly it's
been about a year since like the
beginnings of house and powers of X
right all that stuff that had gone down
and these mutants here right these five
who are ridiculously powerful they are
all under the control of Doom one part
by brainwashing but also because of
loyalty and that's one of the most
important things to understand here
right the the best indication of how
Doom views his people right and how
people operate under doom and why these
mutants are serving him comes by way of
oh my God Jonathan Hickman's Avengers of
New Avengers son son son right you guys
remember that whole scene when like name
of the Submariner goes to Dr Doom and
they have that conversation right
because when the incursion started name
with the Submariner went with the
Illuminati the Illuminati weren't
willing to do what needed to be done so
he sided with Thanos and then Thanos and
his guys just turned bloodlusted and
we're just destroying worlds for the
sake of it as opposed to destroying
alternate Earths to save the main Marvel
Universe there's this point when Neymar
and doom are having this conversation
and literally Doom says like do you
believe that the citizens of this
country couldn't kill me if they chose
to right but I keep them protected I
keep them safe and he says so before
they go to bed at night and pray to
whatever God they believe in they give
thanks to me and that's true it's the
most arrogant thing to say ever and
probably the greatest Dr Doom line
that's ever been with the exception of
what came after that which I think was
even better right it was absolutely
amazing but like it's how people in
laveria View Dr Doom is he like this guy
who's more or less a villain basically
but he keeps his People Protected and to
them that's all they care about seeding
loyalty is the most important thing for
Dr Doom and that's why he tells his
mutants a time is going to come right
with the entire collapse of the mutant
population in kcoa basically in ruin a
time's going to come when the X-Men are
going to arrive here and they're going
to kidnap you and when that happens
remember who saved you remember who
brought you freedom and who kept you
safe from all the humans out there that
are wiping out all those mutants and so
then we jump to basically the ending of
the last issue of the X-Men when
Wolverine and kitty pride and Miss
Marvel Kamala Khan show up here in
Latveria and and immediately these
mutants are sent after them now in terms
of what they can do right there's some
that are explained incredibly well and
some that are not right the really big
guy his name is slack right literally
his blood is magma and his skin is Rock
right there's one called the dreamer
who's basically one of a set of twins
and that he has the ability to enter
into the dreams of people the reason why
this is so amazing for Doctor Doom is
because once that ability is achieved to
its full totality this guy will be able
to to walk in and out of individual's
dreams while they sleep and give that
information to Dr Doom imagine if Dr
Doom had all the secrets of Charles
Xavier or all the secrets of Magneto or
even the different world leaders that
existed out there imagine how much
control he could have now the other one
is iron cloak right she's the other twin
and she has the ability to instill
invulnerability by touching people the
issue is we don't really know how
longlasting it is now neram is somebody
he says my eyes are upon her without
wavering the weather is fair now but I
question her allegiances after the
change of the Season I.E once the
entirety of the mutant population
collapses can I rely on her to stay a
part of my group or will she Branch off
and eventually do her own thing
potentially even join the X-Men now
after that you have volas Spear and he
says she's the finest of them right the
gift of her Doom spere has bonded us she
could be an heir and in fact we'll find
out just how powerful she is and then
the last one whose name we don't know
Doom simply says his powers are too
volatile to control at the moment and so
he shall remain enthralled until
Desperate Measures are called for it's
Dr Doom's Ace in the Hole no clue who
this guy is the Fanboy in me really
hopes it's like some version of like
Matthew Malloy or like Clyde winum or
someone like that just some ridiculously
op reality warper probably not but I'm
hoping that it is but when the fight
breaks out but between these mutants
right Dr Doom's X-Men and the regular
X-Men these guys get crushed I mean they
just get rolled so bad the first one who
steps up is like Volta now the cool
thing about this is that we end up
learning by way of her backstory that
when Wolverine goes to like slash the
spear that she has that like it just
electrocutes the heck out of her right
now one of the things that's interesting
about this and this is kind of a change
that I feel like is being made by Jerry
Dugan who's writing it is is that
Wolverine is seemingly unable to cut
through the spear because it's made of
vibrin now as we know the only material
that can seemingly cut through vibranium
is like anti metal vibranium or just
like Wolverine's atam mantium and that's
it right like everything else cannot
hold a candle to the power of vibranium
but wolver range should be able to cut
through this the response that we get
here is that Kamala con realizes its
vibranium and Dr Doom says the finest
vibranium not like the lowquality shield
stilt legs and assorted Refuge that
you're trained to dodge now some of you
guys might be asking yourselves how in
the world did Dr Doom get his hands on
vibranium one of the things to know here
is that it seems like Jerry Dugan is
tapping into the events of Doom War but
one of the cool things about this and I
don't remember whether or not Doom war
was undone by secret invasion in 2015 I
haven't been I'm not current on Black
Panther full transparency here so I
don't know what all is happening in that
comic but at the end of Doom War all
vibranium across the Earth was rendered
inert it was just useless chunks of rock
right because Dr Doom used all that
vibranium to basically make himself God
temporarily and it was the only way to
defeat him and so it's one of those
things where like maybe they brought it
back I'm not 100% sure if you know Post
in the comments and let me know right
that way I'm informed about what's going
on but the thing about this is that
while Wolverine is of course not
destroyed he is like burnt to a crisp
but that's when you end up end up
picking up with like the nature of Volta
and simply learning that at some point
along the line when her powers
manifested we're not really told that it
was done through puberty it seems to be
a little bit after that that she
basically had the ability to control
lightning she literally was living
lightning and Dr Doom showed up to her
with the vibranium sphere and said this
will enable you to control your powers
now one of the things to know is that it
is all psychological what it does is it
gives her a focusing point right a focal
point and with that focal point she can
now control her abilities with enough
training she wouldn't need it right she
would just be able to control them you
know however it is that she wants to but
for the time being Dr Doom appears here
as a kind of leader of sorts right like
a mentor and then brings her into the
fold now the next person after that and
what's really cool is Kitty Pride goes
to make a move against VTA and what
seems to happen here is Volta uses her
electricity to subdue Kitty Pride now I
don't know if Kitty Pride was intangible
at this point in time it looks like she
wasn't but again one of the things to
know is that kitty Pride can make her
weapons tangible and keep herself
intangible at the same time it's one of
the coolest elements of her character
which has really been showcased in Fall
of X which is why she's so dope but
that's why it's hard to tell
conventional wisdom would lead us to
believe Kitty pride is tangible and
that's how the power worked but wouldn't
it be a cool adjustment here if Volta
could actually hurt Kitty Pride even
though she's intangible that'd be pretty
awesome but following that you literally
have just like slag who runs up on
Kamala Khan now at that moment Wolverine
goes and attacks him but it's not enough
to destroy him because slag doesn't
exists by conventional means I mean
having magma for blood is not enough to
like melt Wolverines out of mantium or
anything like that but he doesn't have
like a particular heart that you can
stab right you can't like slash his gut
open and like his insides come spilling
out it doesn't really work that way
right the other thing about this is that
even in that conflict the twins are
watching this whole thing happen now as
we talked about earlier right the twins
are kind of viewed by Dr Doom as like
his heirs right his proteges the ones
that he prizes above everybody else and
so even where like they want to step in
Doom is simply like no just watch watch
and learn because that's the most
important thing that you can do watching
how the X-Men Fight it's how everybody
who's ever been able to go toe-to-toe
with the X-Men has learned right
watching them fight and so following
that like Nerium shows up and then
attacks him now Nerium is kind of like
Dr Doom's version of like black Tom
Cassidy basically meaning she can
control plant life and she is literally
quote unquote as she refers to it the
life of Latveria right like basically
she's a spirit of the land she can
control the very land itself so her
Vines can be used to heal they can be
used to take people's Powers away
anything that you can imagine plant life
being use for for she can do it even
probably creating all kinds of
pheromones and things that are not
naturally occurring but it's enough to
subdue wol rain and take wolver rain out
and then Kitty Pride as well and so what
ends up happening is that there's a kind
of ceasefire that ends up taking place
right where wolver rain's like okay like
this is it right like this team's
literally dominated us let's
talk right and so it's one of those
things where like the mutants tell them
like we're free here right like we don't
have to worry about Sentinels and things
like that but like we are free in this
place and the response of wol ran is
okay fine then we'll leave you with your
ruler and be on our way and the response
of Doom is I'm afraid you cannot leave
until you've dined with doom because Dr
Doom is the guy who will absolutely
trash you thrash you right like when you
face Dr Doom you are going to be
petrified terrified
horrified humidified but then he'll turn
around and invite you to dinner he'll
turn around like he will beat the crap
out of you and invite you for pancakes
right straight up prince playing
basketball from chapela that's literally
what this is and the cool thing about
this is that this basically grants them
a parlay it's a way for these two groups
to communicate and find what the others
intentions are and one of the things
that like slag brings up and even Volta
brings up here is the fact that the
reality of what's going on out there is
yes humanity is attacking the mutant
population but ity and even orcus isn't
foolish enough to invade Latveria
because Dr Doom by himself given the
amount of power that he has at the
disposal to say nothing of all the
doombots which are arguably equally
powerful to him depending on who's right
in the story they would more than hold
their own against the Sentinels of orcus
orcus would have to bring out an army of
nimrods and even then there's no
guarantee that they would win what I'm
saying here is that it would be a Fool's
errand right they may come out on top
but at what cost so they simply just
don't launch an attack against Dr Doom
because it's the smart thing to do
because of that these mutants are safe
here and even Dr Doom kind of pauses
himself and his forces posit himself as
like maybe you guys should come here
consider this place to be your safe
haven right ask Dr Doom for Asylum but
the thing about this is that in the
midst of this conversation Doom simply
says kcoa was destined to fail right
Charles was not ready for the crown upon
his head I knew my latvians who shared
your genetic lineage were in danger so I
close my borders to you now they are
alive when your people where are they
right they're not anywhere they're not
here the answer to what happens next is
a gift I'm not ready to give but if you
have lived good lives then perhaps you
can call your friends to your side
before you are destroyed and he says as
for the last Cen Xavier is in jail of
his own making either he will destroy
himself or he'll emerge as a much more
interesting person and so he says be
gone by Dawn Doom bids you good evening
and so it's one of these things where
like all that's really left here are the
X-Men and Doom's X-Men and that's what
they say like maybe you can ask for
Asylum here right I mean we're not
leaving but maybe you can ask for Asylum
but one of the things that did take
place here and this is one of the things
that's cool the X-Men have earned the
respect of Doom's forces and so while
they say we are not going to leave this
place right this is a safe haven and
honestly there's no reason for us to
leave if the time comes when a fullscale
war between the human population and the
mutant population happens which is to
say all you mutants are over here and
all the humans are over there and you
guys are just charging at each other
towards some Center Line we will be on
your side you can count on us to join
your cause and that's it right because
literally like the X-Men leave they go
back to New York City to their base of
operations where they look for sink and
the other members of the team only to
find out the whole place is just a blood
bath right it's been ransacked and who
knows what other teammates with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this to an end if you need to get caught
up on fall of X make sure you click this
link to the playlist and I will catch
you all later peace